hi have you ever pondered the potential
profits of mango farming today let's
delve into the lush world of this
tropical fruit exploring its varieties
the ideal climate conditions and the
best farming practices mangoes
delightful and juicy are not just a
favorite fruit for many but also a
profitable Farm investment there are
several varieties of mangoes each with
unique flavors colors and sizes the
Alfonso Kent Tommy Atkins atalo Keat
also known as the mango Manila and
Hayden are some of the most popular and
profitable ones keep in mind however
that different mango varieties have
varying Market values and production
costs climate plays a significant role
in mango farming mangoes Thrive best in
tropical and subtropical climates a
temperature range of 20 to 28° C well-
drained soil ample sunlight and adequate
water supply are essential for growing
healthy juicy M mangoes now let's talk
about farming practices from irrigation
to fertilization Pest Control to disease
management each practice contributes to
the yield and quality of mangoes a
well-maintained Orchard is not only
productive but also profitable for
instance when planting the Kat or apple
mango variety dig holes 60 cm deep and
wide during the dry season the spacing
between trees should be 8 to 12 M
depending on the variety and the areas
climatic conditions this spacing allows
for a population of 36 to 70 trees per
acre grafted plants are recommended as
they yield more and produce fruits
faster Apple mangoes take 3 to 4 years
to mature and start producing fruits a
well-managed tree can produce up to a
th000 fruits per season understanding
the market demand for mangoes in your
region is also crucial government
policies subsidies and support for
agriculture also affect the
profitability of mango farming
adding value to mangoes by processing
them into products like mango Pulp Juice
or dried mango can enhance profitability
choosing mango varieties that are
resistant to common diseases can reduce
the risk of crop loss the size of the
mango Farm also plays a role larger
scale operations May benefit from
economies of scale while smaller Farms
might focus on Niche markets or organic
production a mature kit or apple mango
can produce up to a th000 fruits per
season
if the Farmgate price is 10 Kenyon
Shillings a tree can yield 10,000 Kenyon
Shillings alone what about 100 or 200
trees to your maths export opportunities
also exist however compliance with
export standards and regulations is key
therefore before starting a mango Farm
conduct thorough research soil testing
and market analysis consult experts and
extension services to understand the
specific requirements for mango
cultivation in your region to sum up
mango farming can be a profitable
Venture it requires knowledge of the
best varieties understanding of the
ideal climate conditions and
implementation of effective farming
practices so Ponder upon the potential
of mango farming who knows the seeds you
plant today could bear the fruits of
your success tomorrow don't forget to
comment like share and subscribe for
more insightful farming tips until next
time keep farming